>> SLATKIN: Test, test, hello, hello, hey.
How is it going? All right, I think we're
going to get started. So here, we're still
trickling in but we're all a little bit behind.
Alpha just reminded me if you could please
turn off your Bluetooth devices. I'd really
appreciate it. No, [INDISTINCT]
>> [INDISTINCT] box.
>> SLATKIN: Yeah, yeah, let's [INDISTINCT]
box. So, all right, okay, my name is Brett
Slatkin. I'm a software engineer on Google
App Engine Team. I'm going to tell you today
about how to build a high-throughput data
pipelines on Google App Engine. And be sure,
you know, either--even if you don't stay for
this talk, directly following my talk is another
talk from Mike Aizatsky, who's also in the
team, that'll be talking about the new Mapper
API and our kind of a report generation tools.
This is really a good talk. You should check
out also. So you can view live notes TinyURL
App Engine pipelines or this in my blog, or
you can follow me. So go on there. We also
have a moderator page for questions, so that
you can vote on the questions you want to
ask. Okay, so here's the agenda for today.
So, I'm going to do a little intro. I'm going
to talk about fan-out. I'm going to talk about
transactional sequences, what those are? We're
going to talk about fan-in, it's different.
And we're going to have a little bonus round
in there because I wanted to do more. And
then, we'll talk about the future directions
of what's coming next and where we're going
next. So, this is the wilderness. I--every
year, I get to go of into the wilderness and
kind to think about things and learn about
new ways to count, basically for you. I started
some sharded counters and some right behind
cache. And it seems like every year, I kind
of figure out a new way to count things. And
that's because counting is actually represented
with a very difficult problem. So a lot of
my example--and it's also a difficult problem
if people really easily understand. So, you
know, come back from the wilderness about
a year of experience here, messing around
with data pipelines because of my 20% project.
It's called the PubSubHubbub which is a protocol
in system for making feeds real-time. So I've
had a nice chance to learn about how to build
the data pipeline on App Engine where we run
the Google PubSubHubbub hub. So, I'm back
from the wilderness. So what are pipelines?
What have I learned? Well, pipelines are a
constant trickle of inputs and outputs. They're
an assembly line, okay? They're optimized
for the latency of that line. And usually,
you want it to be on the order of seconds,
right? And the whole idea is to minimize the
incremental cost as much as possible, right?
That's how I would define a pipeline. They're
also not supposed to be lossy. So it's not
like halfway through the assembly line you
lose a car or something like that. So in the
same sense, you don't want to [INDISTINCT]
want to ever lose your data. You want to make
sure that all inputs are served if they're
supposed to be served. So what is not a pipeline?
Offline systems like MapReduce, batch-processing,
any kind of report generation, you know, anytime
you're doing some kind of output from a snapshot
of inputs, that's not, you know, not a pipeline.
You know, if you're doing year-end's calculations
for a finance, that's not a pipeline. That's
just something you do at the end of the year,
all right? And in that case, the latency from
input to output is on the order of hours or
days, not on, you know, in seconds, so to
differentiate. So some actual example apps
so email delivery, Twitter, Hubbub, all kind
of do routing, message routing, those are
pipeline systems. They're latency-sensitive.
Reddit and Digg, they do voting ends. High-throughput
aggregation, that's a pipeline. They want
the time from where you vote to when it goes
up the page to be very low. And even kind
of customer-relationship management software
is kind of a pipeline because you want customers
to work--move through a workflow as quickly
as possible or get passed off between workflow
items as quickly as possible. So there's a
lot of things you can model as a pipeline
that maybe aren't obvious. Things that aren't
pipelines. A guestbook application doesn't
really do much at all, so it's very flat.
Terasort, you know--if you're sorting a ton
of data using MapReduce or some other system,
that's taking a snapshot of data and operating
on it. It's not a living and breathing system.
And then chat is transient, you kind of throw
things away. So that's not a pipeline, although
it has some pipeline aspects. And then hybrid
systems like, you know, basically anything
with what you're doing, you want--you know,
you're latency-sensitive but you actually
kind of have to do batch-processing to achieve
it. So, YouTube and Vimeo both do a lot of
transcoding that takes a lot of time, but
they actually can stream back frames as they're
doing it. So, they're latency-sensitive but
also require a lot of background processing.
Flickr and Picasa do this also with face recognition.
Okay, so let's start off with fan-out. So
this is something that if you've used the
task queue, you kind of have an idea of the
general design pattern here, the idea of having
continuations. So, fan-out is where you have
a single action either from a user or from
some other action in your system causing a
lot of other actions to happen. So a common
use of this is kind of a Datastore-based inbox
system where, you know, you have one person
posting a record and you want a lot of other
people to get it, right? That's fan-out, that's
data fan-out. Sometimes, you also want to
guarantee that notifications get there, so
you want to make sure that, you know, when
somebody submits an expense report or something
like that that no matter what, they always
send an email about it, you know, so that
it never gets dropped. Also, making Web service
calls if you're trying to, you know, communicate
between systems that sometime you might have,
you know, one task that actually needs to
do about 10 different calls. And then, kind
of merge the results or enqueueing more tasks
to do more work. Those are kind of fan-out
tasks where you're branching on multiple patents.
So, here's a really quick example of, you
know, fan-out. So, let's say that I have some
party that I'm putting on, and I have some
partygoers who are going to the party. I have
here, a party class, it's my data model. There's
when the party is and who the host is. And
then, people who are going to the party, so
a reference to the party, who's going, and
their email address, okay? Really simple.
So if I have this and then, I want to send
everyone an email, let me just slowly get
through this. So this is a task request handler.
I'm writing these in Python just because it's
so much shorter and it's easier for me to
just go line-by-line with you. So, but all
the stuff you can do in Java, exactly--almost
exactly the same way, just [INDISTINCT] moving
the white space around. So, that's either
a Python joke or a Java joke depending on
how you see it, right? Okay, so. First, I
find my party from the task parameters--I
find the Datastore cursor if there is one.
I start a new query "PartyGoer.all" filter,
look for people who are going to my party.
And if there is a Datastore cursor, I will
use the cursor with that query which basically
lets me pick up where I left off in the query,
okay? And then, I will send some emails, that's
what that quote is or do anything kind of
fan-out activity, all right, and then, if
I've retrieved 10 partygoers, if you see a
query.fetch(10), I received 10 items from
the query, and so if I did received 10 then
there might be more, so then, I enqueue another
task which is a continuation of this task,
okay? So that's why, it's a continuation,
it's kind of like, you know, maybe if you
do any kind functional programming, you pass
forward a continuation or a call back, right?
So if you do this, the idea is that every
time the next task runs, it'll use the next
cursor which will pick up wherever you left
in your data source scan, do the next little
bit, then it'll do another task and so on.
The problem is that if the task here ever
fails, or your app ever fails, you get a fork
bomb. Each task enqueues new tasks, they fail
right after they enqueue tasks, then they
start again, they enqueue more tasks, you
actually get this exponential explosion of
tasks. If you've ever done basic continuation
passing on App Engine and you know, hit an
error, had a syntax error or anything, you
probably have this happen to you and it's
really terrible. So the task, you know, basically
the one fails then that leads two, and then
the four and the eight and nine, it's just
really terrible. So, that's the wrong way
to do it. And it doesn't really take much
to prevent this from happening. All you have
to do is name your task. That's it. So in
App Engine, tasks have this property called
the name, you get to assign it. Here, I'm
just assigning it a sequence number. I'm saying
the generation numbers starts at 0. So the
first task is generation 0 then I do 1, 2,
3, and I add 1, okay? So, it's exactly the
same code like do the query, figure out what
you're going to do, do the work for fan-out,
then enqueue another task, okay? But you also
notice at the bottom, I'm sending some emails
after, I enqueue the next task as supposed
of before. And the reason I do that is because
it lets me actually get more parallelism.
Essentially, I'm querying for the work to
do. I figure out where the endpoint is and
then, I immediately enqueue the next task
to do the same thing before sending my emails,
because sending my email is a high latency
activity, right? So I should be able to, you
know, pass the baton to the next task to find
the next people to send the emails to and
then, still do my work. So what you end up
with is this nice kind of cascade of tasks
where each one queries the next little bit
of work then enqueues the next one, and then
so on and so forth. So they actually will
be overlapping as they execute, which is really
nice. And because you've named them, our task
queue system on App Engine has the ability
to tombstone tasks. That means that you can
only add a task with the same name once every
7 days. That's how it works. So if you re-add
the same task, it'll raise an exemption to
you and say, "You have already added this
task." The other thing is that, you know,
besides just your own coding mistakes, the
task queued isn't a perfect system, it might
run task more than once. That's part of the
kind of scalability trade-offs that we've
made with the system like that. So, this kind
of gives you a level of idempotents on your
tasks. Basically, you're saying, "Hey, if
this task gets added multiple times, that's
all right." So in this case, you know, task
1 and task 3 spuriously have run and they
maybe send new emails to that small number
of people but they don't cause a fork bomb.
They don't cause an exponential number of
additional tasks to be added, okay? So, every
time, you know, say task 1 spuriously gets
called, it'll enqueue task 2 and it'll--and
that will return an error and saying, "This
task query exists, so don't do the next piece
of work." So this is the way to do a continuation
passing. It's basically, figure out the cursor,
add the task, and then actually do the work
you want to do with names. So that's--like
I was saying, this isolates the failures and
your spurious retries, and lets you execute
the work in parallel, which is great. The
other thing is that it works really well in
asynchronous APIs. So, if you ever have a
situation where you have high-latency, you
want to iterate through a bunch of things
in parallel, and each one takes about 10 seconds,
but you want to get them all done in a short
period of time. If you do the query at the
beginning of the continuation, you can start
passing that baton immediately. And so, you
know, as soon as you enqueue the task, it'll
start running within, you know, 5, 10 milliseconds.
So you'll get, you know, 50 threads running
in parallel or something like that. So that's
really a nice way to get a lot of work done
all at the same time and do fan-out to--for,
you know, a higher-level of parallelism. And
so we use this technique in the hub. And we
do between 100 and 300 worker request per
second all day long using this style. So,
it's really effective. It works very well.
And we've had async URLFetch in Python. This
has been Java support since February. There's
also some really cool tools in Python and
Java for doing asynchronous Datastore calls
which you should definitely check out async
tools and Twigg. They do a lot of asynchronous
stuff of features and it's just really great
as a programming model. It's much more efficient
than maybe what you're used to. So definitely
check those out. Okay. So, the next step--we
got a lot of ground to cover, that's why I'm
going kind of quick. It makes sense so far?
Any questions so far? Yes.
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> SLATKIN: Yeah.
>> SLATKIN: So, is that--yeah, every time
you run these things in parallel or in sequence,
you lose--yeah, I'm repeating the question.
So the question is, "Every time you run tasks
in parallel or in sequence, you lose atomicity."
Yes, you lose atomicity. Absolutely, that's
part of the deal. I'm getting into how to
keep that if you need to. That's part of the
trade-off of fan-out. Basically, you're saying,
"I know I need the fan-out." And then, if
you need to apply some kind of atomicity or
sequencing, then that's where you get in to
transactional sequences, so. Yes, natural
question, that's why it's the next topic.
So, how do you--how do you guarantee [INDISTINCT]
across tasks? Okay, so what is a transactional
sequence? So, we've had this for a little
while. Some people don't know it but you can
actually use Datastore transactions with tasks
at the same time. What that means is that
you can commit a transaction and a task at
the same time, which means that the task will
not ever run until after the data has been
committed. And that the data won't get committed
unless the task will run. So, you are guaranteed
that they will both be in or out, right? You
don't have any extra tasks. You don't have
any missing data. So that means, you have
strong consistency when the task is run and
you can do all kinds of really cool things
with that pair. Specifically, what it'll let
you do is something like roll-forward semantics
to fanned-out data. So, I'll explain what
that is, but in a nutshell, you can have roll-forward
materialized views. So, what is a materialized
view? If you're a database person, you probably
have heard that term before. So a materialized
view is just a query that you saved back into
the database. That's all it is, do the query,
save it back in the database. The reason you
want to do that is because you want to read
from it a lot. You want to cache it a lot.
Or maybe, it's an index that's, you know,
more complicated required some work that you
don't want to have to keep doing. And a lot
of the time, it's eventually consistent. So,
with the materialized view, you don't care
if it's perfectly transactional as long as
it's eventually correct, provides a good picture
of what's going on. And so, a materialized
view also lets you do all kinds of cool tricks
like you can do incremental aggregations like
counts and sums. You can do natural and left-joints
pretty easily. And you can do all kinds of
filtering and querying on those materialized
results. So you can do a level of richness
in querying that you couldn't do otherwise.
So let me show you what I mean. So, here's
a SQL statement. This is something that people
do a lot, grade would be like, you know, first
grade, second grade, you know, as kids gets
older, not like A, B, or C. So, we have Bob
and Daisy on the student table, what grade
they're in. And here, I can figure out, you
know, "SELECT grade, count(*) as count FROM
Student GROUP BY grade;" basically. So I'm
saying, you know, what--how many people are
in each grade? It's really simple statement
you can do in SQL, and it's something that's
actually kind hard to do in App Engine. So
how would you build this on App Engine if
you want to do and make sure that it was correct?
It's like that it eventually always came to
the correct answer. And so, what you can do
is you can build a materialized view which
is this lower table, which gives you the grade-to-count
mapping, right? And then, you can do all kinds
of cool stuff for like that. Like you could
render the front page of people, you know,
with grades or maybe the dig name page, you
know--a bunch of stuff. So, let me show you
how to do it on App Engine. So, this is the
same model--same model as SQL. I'm just kind
of giving you a little more, you know, syntax
around it so you understand exactly how it
works. So we have a student model class here.
That's the person. That's the first table.
It's who and what grade they're in, okay?
Then we have this marker class which is actually
just a random entity. I'll explain how it
works. This is what we use for sequencing.
And then, at the bottom we have the group
count. Which says, for each grade, what is
the count? So that's--the actual materialized
view is the group count. That's what that
is, okay? So, this is the idea. You have,
you want to have roll-forward semantics that
means the data rolls forward. That means that
like at any time all that matters is what
is the next thing in the sequence of events?
All you care about is the latest value. So
any time data falls behind you, you just want
to roll it forward. That's all you care about.
That's what we're trying to achieve. We're
not trying to have perfect transactional consistency
across all of our inputs and our aggregations.
We're just trying to make sure that it's eventually
correct so that it reach to some stable value
without any potential conflicts. So we have
Bob, let's say that Bob gets held back or
push back maybe on a fight, I don't know.
So we're changing his grade from 4 to 3, sad.
And he's a student. And so, we make a new
child entity, that's kind of a weird--weird
relationship, but let's say the student has
a child entity which is the marker, okay?
So you remember this marker. The marker has
a sequence number. And has a property of whether
or not is present. I'll get into what that
means. But when Bob's grade change comes in,
so someone typing in the change, we increment
the sequence number, let's say it was 16 before.
This is just any sequence numbers. It's just
an ordering for the events, the changes. So
this is the change number 17 that we're doing.
We apply that to this child entity, and this
is part of a whole transaction. So then, we
transactionally, step 3, enqueue two tasks.
One task says, "Hey, update the old value--the
old aggregations. Say, that Bob is no longer
in the 4th grade." And the other one is update
the new value and say that Bob is now on the
3rd grade. So we can update the materialized
view from the source data. But we update the
source data in a transactional way so that
it's consistent and atomic on the source.
So then we commit the transaction and the
tasks run. So, let me just show you the code
for the update. So this is the update function,
I'm defining a transaction. I have--as parameters
to the update function, I have the name of
the student, I have the new grade that they're
going to be in, and I have their student ID.
So if the ID exists, like this is a new student,
I'll get the student and then I'll keep track
of what their old grade was and then I'll
update their grade to the new grade. That's
just a little swap line, that old student
grade. If they don't have an ID, then I'll
create the new student, assign an ID by putting
it and then do the same thing. And note that
they didn't have an old grade, so I don't
have to remove them. Then I go and retrieve
the marker which is the sequencing entity,
and I pull it out of the Datastore. If it
doesn't exist, I also create it. That's this
"if not marker: Marker = [INDISTINCT]". That's
just, you know, kind of get it create. And
then I increment the marker sequence number.
So this is how I guarantee atomicity of the
student's record and what grade they're in,
okay? So this is just finding the student
and then saying, "They were sequence number
16, now they're sequence number 17, and their
grade is changing from 4 to 3." So that's
what I've done. I assigned their new grade
level. I kept track of the old one. So, you
see, "old, student.grade = student.grade,
new." So that means the old grade will equal
the new--the old grade and the new grade will
equal to new grade, okay? That's all I'm doing.
And I'm saying that this is the 17th change
or the nth change to this user's data, so
it's atomic, it's an order. So then I put
those back on the Datastore. I enqueue a task
transactionally, that's what that "transactional
= true" is. I say this student ID has this
grade now. The sequence number is, say, 17
and they're present. That means that they're
now in this grade, okay? Then, I also say,
"Hey, if the old one is not None, that means
they had a previous grade." That means that
they were--they've been moved between grades
so they graduated or whatever. And then I
also enqueue another task for the same student
except grade is old. So I take the old grade,
and then you'll notice that I use the same
sequence number but then I set presence to
false. So I say that they are not present
in the old grade because they've been moved
out of the old grade. That was the point because
we move Bob from grade four to grade three.
And then I run that in the transaction--sorry,
I run the transaction that commits transaction.
So all we've done here is change their grade
from four to three and then enqueued two tasks
transactionally that are guaranteed to run
with the sequence number. So, okay, these
are the models again, just to show you. So
that's the sequence ID, the marker. So now
what happens? So let's say this is our initial
state. On the left, we have the aggregation
group count for the third grade--I'm sorry,
for the fourth grade, okay? This is a parent
entity which is the count. This is the aggregation.
This is the fourth grade, how many people
are in it? That's all there is to it, right?
The one on the right is, "For the third grade,
how many people are in it?" Okay? Now, child
entities of this group counts or these markers
I was telling you about, these are the things
that they use for sequencing. They indicate
if a student is actually been present in the
aggregation, okay? So you'll notice here that
Bob was in the fourth grade. On the left side,
he has an entity that says he was present.
It has sequence number 16. Okay. And it has
a plus, which means that he's present. That
means he's in that grade. On the right side,
you'll see that Bob also has sequence number
16, but he's got the presence indicator of
negative, which means he does not contribute
to the aggregation. Okay? So then what we
do is these tasks come in, the two tasks that
we enqueued before, these two here, the run
tasks, the two we enqueued, they run. So watch
the left side. So we created--did the transaction
here and we update these two values. We say,
"Transactionally, Bob is no longer in this
grade." Update the transactional sequence
from 16 to 17 to make sure that it's ordered
and then reduced the group count from three
to two. So we're just taking him out of the
grade transactionally. And we're sequencing
it with that sequence number. That's how we
make sure that we don't mess up. We did the
exact opposite on the other side, we take--we
do another transaction. This is in a second
task and it updates the group count to three
and then marks Bob as present, okay? That's
all that's going on. So, who coded this? Oh,
it's not wrapping right. Oh, it's okay, all
right. So to apply this, this is what the
task does. It has a sequence number. It has
whether or not they're present, the new grade
they're going to be--the grade I'm affecting
and the ID of the student. So then, it figures
out the keys, start the transaction and it
says, "Give me the aggregation count or the
aggregation row," which is the group count
entity, and the marker, which is "For the
student, is Bob present as part of this aggregation?"
Then it creates both the group count and the
marker if they don't exist already. And then
there's this important line, if "marker.sequence"
is greater than sequence, roll back. This
is the kind of magical part of this. Okay?
This is when I'm talking about, roll-forward
semantics. This is what I'm talking about.
So if we accidentally moved Bob from grade
four to grade three, and then back to grade
four again, we don't care what order the events
come in because we know that when we changed
it, it went sequence number 16, 17, 18. So
if you look at the aggregation and 18 is already
there, marker.sequence = 18, and the incoming
task is from mark--sequence number 17, you're
like, "Oh, I already knew this. I already
applied this. I don't care about this anymore
because it's an old update. I can ignore it.
I'm rolling forward my data. That's the point."
So you're going to just drop the old stuff.
And the roll-back will actually cause running
transaction to return without any kind of
exceptions. So it'll look like it was successful,
which is what you want. So then on the next--the
next step is in that transaction. I just say,
"Okay. This is transaction number 17. I assign
it. And I keep track of kind of what the--whether
or not they were present before. That's what
that old value is. I put the sequence number
back in there, "db.put(marker)", that's what
I do. That's me updating the sequence number
to keep this atomic property. If they were
present before, then I subtract. If they are
present now, then I add one. I could probably
write that better but just trying to make
it really clear. If the count is now zero,
that means there's nobody in the grade anymore.
So I just delete the grade. I don't want that
table--I don't want that row in my aggregation
table. And then I either put the group or
I delete it, and then I run that in the transaction.
Okay? So, again, the idea is that we're rolling
forward these two independent entity groups
at separate times but able to keep atomicity
across them. That's like the really cool thing.
Just to hit you over the head with this again,
so here's the sequence of what we're doing.
Number one, change the student grade; two,
increment their sequence number, so 16 to
17, old grade is four, new grade is three;
three, enqueue two tasks; four, tasks are
running. We fetch the grade group, we compare
the sequence numbers, we see that the current
one is 16, 16 is less than 17, we allow the
transaction roll-forward to happen. We increment
the count. That's all there is to it. It's
really simple. So let me show you this. I
have this running. Let's see. I think it's
this one. Okay. So this is my little demo.
I'll be making this code available soon, so
there's me in sixth grade and Jim in the second
grade. You can add one in the fourth grade,
click "Add", okay? There we go. Now, I'm going
to move Jim into the fourth grade. See if
it reloads. Here we go. Okay. So there's two
students in grade four, so, you shouldn't--now
this happens so fast, you're like, "Well,
Brett, you're just doing that, you know, with
the covers or whatever." It's happening so
fast. Well, that's because task queues run
really fast, you know. But just to show you,
these are my admin logs. So you'll see, here's
a 302, that's what I return when I--302 right
here, that's what I return when I have a successful
post. Now, you'll see two work items run.
One, removing it from grade four and one adding
it to grade six for the same student. Okay?
That's all I'm doing, really easy. But that
happens so fast. You'll see--look at the time,
it's 33.36, 33.72, 33.73, 33.8, so the task
ran from my browser even reloaded the page.
It's pretty cool. Okay. So, some final details
about this. So each aggregation row is its
own entity group. That's how this works, that's
how you guarantee that the aggregation rows
stay consistent within themselves. You update
them in several transactions and the order
of the task application doesn't matter. And
then that marker entity, child of each row
basically indicates the present of that--presence
of that student in the aggregation. So that's
how you do this. That's how you bridge the
transactions across these entity groups. And
the roll-forward part is that you can just
ignore old updates because you don't care.
It works really well for a commutative operations,
count, sum. If you're toggling presence, it's
really easy. You can actually do with some
ancestor queries in that transaction because
it's across the same entity groups. So if
you need to do something like some squares,
it's actually possible. And you can actually
use continuations with cursors to do multiple
transactions comparing sequence numbers all
along the way to actually do really elaborate
functions on all of your aggregation data.
That's more complicated and more expensive
computationally, but it's kind of a simple
model of doing work like this in a deferred
manner. So it's definitely something to check
out. And you can kind of keep your aggregations
accurate, which is really nice. And then you
can fan-out. So when the source data changes,
you can enqueue multiple tasks and update
many aggregations at the same time, so you
don't have--you're not limited to just one
materialized view, you can have many different
ones for the same data. Now, the thing is
though, the key--the gotcha is that the maximum
throughput is proportional to how many aggregation
rows you have. You need to do transactions
on each of those aggregation rows as you apply
the transforms. So if you only end up having
one aggregation row, then you actually are
going to be limited to updating that--how
fast that one aggregation row can update,
right? And usually, you want to limit that
to about one transaction per second per aggregation
row to make sure they have no comflicts and
no, you know, kind of a roll-back transactions,
transaction collisions. So that's a problem.
For a lot of apps though that are trying to
do complicated aggregations, they don't--really
don't care. That's actually--they just want
the functionality. The other thing is you
create a storage cost for the presence entity.
So to even indicate that, an aggregation contains
one of the students for instance, you need
to write a little row. But that row is usually
on the same size--it's about the same size
of the actual key of the original data, so
it's like a hundred bytes or so. You don't
have to index it anyway. So you can do some
really nice things with those presence indicators
to make them really cheap. Okay. I want you
to hold off on that one, I'm going to, maybe
I'll descend that one too. So, all right,
so this gets to the next problem, you know,
if I'm limited to one transaction per second
that's not really good and I actually need
to do a lot of work in batch a lot of the
time. And what I find in building a pipeline
in this system is that I often needed to do
a lot of work in batch, so that's when I want
to fan-in. So what is fan-in? So it means
applying multiple data transforms in a batch,
doing work in batches, taking counter updates,
aggregation updates, roll-ups of event data,
you know, reservations of different resources,
doing them all at the same time. For instance,
with Reddit or Digg-style voting, once a second
you can just pull for every update and then
save the new values, you know, you only have
apply what's changed since the last time you
looked, right? So it's fan-in, you take a
bunch of events that have come from a lot
of different sources, combine them and aggregate
them together into a single batch of work.
And this lets you, not as only--well, you
can beat the one second per entity group right
throughput problem with this aggregation rows
because you can batch up your work into smaller
pieces. It's also really good for high latency
API calls. So if you're doing a lot of URL
fetches or doing any kind of, you know, complicated
data sub-queries or a lot of these queries
at the same time. If you're building RSS aggregator
or you need a lot of throughput it's really
good for that. Make sure that your queues
don't back up. So that's when you want to
do fan-in. Basically, any time you want to
amortize the cost of doing a lot of work and
you can do that by doing it in parallel? You
want to fan-in and--so that parallel--you
can do your work in parallel at the same time
that's like pretty obvious idea. So, the problem
is that when people do this in the real world,
they usually think of it this way. So, in
the real world like the outside of Google,
I guess, the fantasyland of my wiliness. So,
they have a queue and have a queue moderator
and have a bunch of workers and they pop off
the head, maybe they grab five at a time or
20 at a time, right? And that's how basically
every other queuing system out there works
and it works really well for a lot of things.
The problem is the workers are always running.
And then what happens is, you know, remember
we're trying to build a pipeline here. So
how many polling workers do you need to make
sure that if you're inserting 50 tasks a second,
that each one of service within 500 milliseconds?
And then what if the tasks take a long time,
each one? And then how do you make sure that
the workers don't stand on each others--step
on each others toes, right? Like there's a
whole series of problems that come out of
polling based workers. They can batch but
they can't actually guarantee the latency
that you need. So I would claim that polling
workers actually don't work for offline processing.
Oh, sorry, polling workers are offline processing
they don't work for pipelines, that's what
I'm saying. Polling workers cannot do pipelines.
They're not dynamic. The latency is not low
enough. You have to have workers allocated
for your peak load at all times because you
need to make sure that you can guarantee those
latency--that latency margin. And it basically
eliminates--if you're doing polling, it eliminates
the benefits of the push based task queue
that App Engine has, okay? So what I've--what
I would like to use instead is a fork-join
queue, okay. Well, the fork-join queue is--it's
a queue were as work comes, we fork the items
apart into different segments, okay? And then,
we make sure that all of that work will start
within a fixed interval after arrival, so
each piece of work will be guaranteed to run
within 500 milliseconds. Then we execute the
work in those batches, so we fork it and then
execute it in batches, and then at any time
we can join that work back with some other
data records to leave the system that's the
join part, that's optional, but it's part
of the same kind of idea, so I'm going to
show you exactly what I mean. So here is a
fork-join queue that uses the Datastore along
with the task queue. So, ideally, I would
like to have two batches run in parallel for
two 500 millisecond periods let's say. So
time is going to the right, so a new work
item comes in, inserts it to the Datastore,
so this is some work I need to do, so if I
need to fetch, this is a vote on an item that
I need to upload. And then when I insert that
item, I also insert a task within ETA of 500
milliseconds in the future. So presumably
that task will run after the first batch has
queued up, right? That's what I'm trying to
do. So then I insert another work item, and
then I insert the task again but the task
is already there, that's that first property
when we're going through continuations that
what happens. The task [INDISTINCT], so you're
guaranteed that if you insert it two times
basically, that it only will run once, okay?
So that's the fan-in, that's the magical part
but the task is already there. So the task
will only actually run once, so I can insert
more work, again, I get the task, the conflicts
and it just skips it. The same thing, so the
batch is full. I've got a whole 500 milliseconds
worth of work and then I execute the task
and I take care of that batch. It's a straightforward
idea. Now the next batch starts. Start queuing
work again, with the task which starts after
the batch two and so on. So it seems great,
right? It's really easy. The problem is that
how do you coordinate when the batches start
and stopped? So people will like "Well, let's
just use the clock, right?" Every 500 milliseconds
just pick the current time and then pick on
the clock where you want it to start and boom
you got it, except clocks aren't in-synch.
It doesn't work like that, even with NTP it
doesn't work like that. I saw a server the
other day, it was 40 minutes off, so, yeah,
not good. So we need another way to do that
and there is another problem. What happens
if there's a race condition right at the edge
where the task just starts to execute? Write
is another--or you know, the task executes
and finds a works it needs to run just as
another work items is inserted. How does the
task know to wait? So we actually kind of
need a lock there. We need to make sure that
the task doesn't run until the entire batch
is committed. So that's a problem, right?
Similarly, if we have one of those machines
that has a terrible clock, what if it inserts
into the wrong batch? Or inserts into a box
that already executed a long time ago? We
needed ways to prevent those things too. So
time alone doesn't work, we need something
better. So let me show you how to do it. So
here I have some--another it's me counting
again, next day I'm going to wear cape that
will be good. So I have my sum, here is an
aggregation of me counting. I have my work
which is delta space [INDISTINCT] that I want
to apply to the sum. And then each piece of
work has a work index which I'll explain what
that is and then the sum has a name, okay?
Really simple. But you can think of the sum
is saying like, this is the most popular dig
item right now and my work is my upload, okay.
So, I'll be on my, my wrapping does not look
good, I'm sorry about that. It will be okay.
It's--yes, that fits right? So insert, this
is inserting a work item, this is inserting
a upload or delta, a positive delta, negative
delta. I have the sum name and then the delta
amount, that's my two parameters to the function.
I will call "memcache.get" on an index. Okay.
So this is a counter that represents my batches,
my batch count. So what I want to do here
is instead of using time for batch one, batch
two, so I have, you know, 500 milliseconds
in the future, 1 second in the future, 1.5
seconds in the future. What I'm going to do
is actually assign sequence numbers. Batch
one, batch two, batch three, batch four; and
that's how I'm going to assign these groupings
of this tasks. So I did that with memcache,
I do "memcache.get" on the index. If the index
isn't there I add it starting at one and then--and
so then I have my work index. So how I know--this
is the next batch number that I'm going to
use. Then I looked at memcache and I looked
at the lock. This is a reader/writer lock
that I'm doing in memcache. Okay. Memcache
is extremely fast for doing a reader/writer
lock. So I do a memcache increment and I increment
the lock with this name. I'm formatting a
string here; I'm just putting the sum name
and the index number into a memcache key.
Okay, that's all I'm doing. So if my sum were,
you know, stuff, it would be "stuff-lock-index"
so and, you know, 400 or something. So I do
memcache increment to that, that's atomic.
And the initial value I set 2 to the 16th.
I'll explain that in a second why we need
to do that. Now this will get a little hairy
and I'll come back to exactly how it works
but if the number--so I did the increment,
it gives me back the new value of this lock,
this reader/writer lock. It's more like a
semaphore. If the writer is way less than
2 to the 16th or anything less than 2 to the
16th, I basically know that this lock is no
longer--this index is no longer available
to new writers, okay. So you cannot use this
index anymore. It's what that negative is,
that if writers is less than 2 to the 16th
that's saying, the index you just selected
on the first line, memcache.get, this index
you can't use anymore. That solves the race
condition of the task queue and the batch
coming at the same time. So in that case,
I decrement the lock, I'm like "All right,
drop this lock." And I return false. This
failed I didn't get to insert the work item.
If you want to make sure that's totally reliable,
you just keep spinning until you get in one.
Memcache is fast enough, you usually have
to try it like at most twice. Okay. But that's
just solving the race condition of the synchronization
at the end of the batch. So then once I have
incremented the lock, that means I have incremented
the writer lock, I have registered that I
am a writer for this lock, I'm going to be
writing so that, you know, keep track of that
as if like a semaphore. So I add one to that
reader/writer lock. Then I add--take my work,
I set the delta to whatever I supply, you
know, add 1, minus 10 whatever. I set the
work index property to the index I got with
the sum name and then a hash value; I'll get
into "Y." This hash is just [INDISTINCT] hash
and then I put in the work committed to the
Datastore. Then I do the batching part and
all I'm doing is I'm taking the present time
and I'm saying "I want to have some work start
one second from now." So take the current
time, add one second, ETA, it's me setting
an ETA, you can do it countdown too, either
way. But the important thing here is I'm setting
the task name, the task name is that the sum
name plus now over 30, I'll explain why that's
there, and the index, which means that if
a hundred at work items all have to do this
at the same time, they'll all fan-in magically.
One of them will succeed and all the rest
will go into this exception handler, task
[INDISTINCT] that exists there. And I passed
there, which means I don't care. Okay. Now,
once I've put the work item, it's the last
line, put I've--so, I've created my work item,
I have assigned it a batch number, I put it
in the Datastore, I have in queued the task,
then I decrement the reader/writer lock. That
means I'm no longer a writer on this lock.
I'm done. And I returned true to the writer.
So it's relinquishing the writer lock. So
this lock allows multiple writers and a single
reader, that's what we're trying to do. All
right, let's take a little break. A lot of
code. So, now, joining, this is taking all
the batch items and running them together.
So first thing I do, this is the task running,
this is the task I enqueued, that's were the
join is happening. So, all of these input
items, enqueued the same tasks in a 500 milliseconds
in the future. Eventually, the task wakes
up and it starts running. And it knows its
own index because it's encoded in the names.
See that taskqueue add name equals, the index
is the last parameter. It knows its own index.
Okay. So when the task wakes up it knows its
name and its index. So then it will memcache
increment, it will push the batch index forward,
it says "Okay, batch number 400 is done I'm
closing the gate." Push it forward so that
batch 401 has to happen. Okay. So it's pushing
things forward. Then it goes to the lock that
same reader/writer lock and it's decrements
it by a huge number. And this is the--you
miss the boat signal. This basically handles
the race condition exactly at the border line
when the items or sequence in such way that
the writer beat the task of getting the index
before this first increment. So basically
the writer grabs 400 and then starts committing--oh,
sorry--it grabs 400 and then starts to increment
the lock. So that's the race that you're trying
to solve there. And by decrementing it massively
negative like this decrement 2 to 15th. That's
what allowed us to do this if a writer isn't
less than 2 to 16th. All right, so just making
sure that like I thought I acquired the writer
lock but I actually didn't. That's all your
able to detect. So if writer's is less than
2 to 16th, what that actually says is the
task is already running right these very second.
It's actually two threads running at the same
time. It's given me a synchronization primitive
between my active writing code and my reading
code that's what that does. That's the actual
mechanism. So now in the task, because I have
multiple threads running at the same time
and I have the synchronization primitive,
what I do is I need to wait for the writers
to finish. So sometimes the Datastore might
take up to a second or two seconds depending
on, you know, what you're doing, how big your
data is, whatever. So here actually just busy
wait and I keep getting that lock, its current
value, and I wait for all of the writers to
finish. So as soon as the counter goes back
to a known value, basically, the zero point,
then I'm like "All right, cool. All the writers
are done I can now do my actual work." Okay.
And you can set a timeout here to give up
after a few seconds. But the end of the day
all we've done, all we've achieved here is
we're being able to batch a bunch of work
up at the same time. So it will execute--execute
in parallel. So this is how I actually get
to work, it's just index by the work index.
I say give me all the work with this index,
give it all to me, so do a filter, give me
a list of everything, sum up all the deltas
for all the results, and then apply them in
a transaction to my sum. Okay. So results
equals that's the query to get all the work
with the certain index. Delta's just the sum.
The transaction just gets the sum, creates
it if it's not there. Applies a delta and
submit it. At the end I delete the items if
I wanted to.
So you see, again, inserting work into the
Datastore and as the work gets inserted it
gets a batch sequence number, inserts a tasks
with that sequence number. Then the next work
items do the same thing, right? Same sequence
number that they have. As soon as the task
runs it prevents that sequence number from
being used again. And then there are some
extra fancy bits around the reader and writer
lock to make sure that this case were you
insert the work right at the exact same time
the task is running, doesn't cause you to
drop things. Okay? It guarantees that it completes.
It's kind of--that's the hard magical part
about this. Okay. So a demo, let's see. All
right, so this is really a great app, this
is like one of the best ones I've ever written.
It just says true. So that just means it inserted
some data. I was going to run httperf but
apparently my laptop doesn't have [INDISTINCT]
right now. That's news to me. Yeah, I know,
sad. So--and so again, I'll show you my admin
logs. Hopefully, I caught it fast enough.
Okay. So you see here, these are me doing
increments with name, the sum name is food,
the delta is one. They all get the same sequence
number, insert a task, and then the work will
actually batch it up. So it says I'm combining
five tasks into a delta of five. That's what
it did. And there are no race conditions.
It's fanned-in. It's much more efficient.
You can do all the database work in parallel.
It's really great. So the details again, the
task names are the fan-in mechanism. That's
the magic here. That's how we do it. We use
the task ETA for the periodic batching. We
use memcache for reader/writer lock so that
the batches can coordinate to make sure that
you don't start reading before the writers
are done. And then we used spin locks to make
that coordination work correctly. And last,
we used the Datastore to go and find the actual
works. So we apply this work index to our
data, the batch ID, the batch number, so we
actually just query for it in the Datastore.
And then if you do are getting any drops for
whatever reason like if you have a more lossy
data model you can use an offline job to pick
those up. But given the scheme, you shouldn't
have to. And it scales all the content. So
depends on your batch size, obviously, the
data format you have, the model you have,
I just ran a few tests with this code. The
model I was testing with was larger but I
can insert, you know, basically up to 75 items
per second. The latency didn't change. So
just batching up every second works really
well, it's great. Now, some important details
about the performance, the work index has
to be hash. You have to hash it. That's why
I didn't use hash. And the reason is that
you need to do that so that you distribute
the load across BigTable. A naive batching
of limitation might use a timestamp to do
this. The problem with timestamps is they're
always increasing. So in BigTable, you're
always writing to the beginning of the same
row. BigTable always does things in order,
right? So if you are ordering things by time
descending, you're basically always writing
into the same rows. So every time the tablet
gets overloaded or gets too much data, it's
going to split itself in half and then keep
doing it. But you'll just keep pounding the
same one over and over again. You don't actually
split the load. So by putting a hash in your
work index you're making sure that you fan-out
your works so that some of your writes go
over here and some go over here and some go
over there. That's how you gain the--that's
how you get the parallelism of the fan-in.
The other thing you need to do, if you really
want a lot of throughput on this is to eliminate
all the other indexes you have, like global
indexes. Composite indexes are fine because
usually they're prefaced to the unique key.
But global indexes have the same problem where
if you're writing the ETA or update time of
an entity, that's in a global index, that
top of the list BigTable tablet server will
be unhappy. But the other thing you see, I'll
say here you can keep indexes in your "boxcar"-ing
transactions. So what I'm saying there is
that if the whole point of this is just to
make it so you can do more work per transaction,
then you really don't care so much about the
BigTable fan-out. All you're trying to do
is say apply a hundred manipulations to the
same entity group at the same time. So you're
just trying to do all your writes in combinations
so you can kind of move faster. But you're
not actually trying to do like a hundred updates
per second, right? The last thing, I don't
have too much time for, but it's just this
magic batch period equals zero. So in my testing,
which is fine--and I been using this--I meant
to mention--I've been using this in the PubSubHubbub
hub for a few days now at scale. So it works
very well, it actually reduced my total footprint
by about 40%. So it's pretty serious. I actually
use a batch period of zero. And what that
means is I wait for as long as the Datastore
takes to put. That's my batching period. So
I start that put. And that's how long I'll
wait, so sometimes it's 50 milliseconds, sometimes
it's 10, sometimes 100, so it's just kind
of expands based on my latency. And that kind
of creates a self-regulating system that's
really cool. So you can experiment with that
and there some more advanced code to do that,
some of it to just think about. All right,
I've only got a few minutes left. I just have
one last slide then I'm basically done. All
right, that was probably a lot. That's the
most code I put on the screen. So I appreciate
you bearing with me. So hopefully, if you've
been thinking about this, the obvious combination
of this thing is you can take fan-in fork-join
queues and the transactional sequences and
materialized views, put them together and
get something really cool. And that's right.
You can. That's the point that's what I'm
getting at. This is a huge wall of text. Don't
even look at it. Don't even look at it. It's
just for me. Okay. So here's what you do,
you have a fork-join queue that batches once
per second. The user updates some data like
their votes. Okay. I upvote this item. They
insert that data and they get a work index
for their fork-join queue. And apply that
to their vote. Okay? That's basically saying
they add it into a fork-join queue. Then they
transactionally insert some tasks to go and
update their materialized view. Then you also
go and insert the--optimistically you insert
some name fan-in task. That's to do the magical
batching what the fork-join queue requires.
And then later on, the fan-in worker will
query for all of the votes that have come
in, in the last, you know, one second. And
then it'll do a transaction on all of the
rows that make that--make up that aggregation
like the total votes for an item. It'll fetch
all of the markers. It'll compare the batch
work that it just got in with what's present
at the current time. It'll figure out the
difference of what's present and what's not
present, like if someone changed their vote
from upvote to downvote, it will do that with
sequence numbers to make sure it has row-forward
semantics, and then it will update the aggregation
row and commit. So what does this mean? What
does this means is that you can actually get
a lot of throughput out of those aggregation
rows I was telling you about. The materialized
view thing I was telling you about, you can
actually write to those like a hundred updates
per second but you just have to do it in batches
of a hundred ones per second. So you can combine
the materialized view stuff I've told you
about today with the fork-join stuff, put
them together and get a very high throughput
aggregation system to do all the aggregations
you want, which is just great. So please build
this and send it to me or our team would love
to see that. It's something you can do in
user space. I wish I had more time. So, yeah,
thanks for bearing with me. So, okay, the
last slide; future directions, so, now, you're
probably asking me, you know, this could be
a lot more efficient if I could go faster
or longer batch more, right, and we're working
on it. This is on a road map. We want to have
background servers. These are servers that
have no wall clock limits. That means we don't
have a 30-second deadline anymore. So then
it's important to us for the purpose of pipelines
like this and for the next talk about the
map--the Mapper API. We want you to be able
to chunk through these fan-in queues in bulk
like huge amounts of bulk. It would also be
even faster if I can do--have addressable
servers running on App Engine so that every
time a new work item comes in, I would just
send a remote procedure call to some running
server and have it enqueue in memory that
would make this extremely fast. It'd be lossy,
but it would be, you know, an order of magnitude
faster. So we're working towards this kind
of efficiency goals for both pipelines and
for offline processing both in the form of
backgrounds servers and addressable servers.
So this is a ton of road maps that something
that we think is really important. Okay. We
got a little bit of time for questions, Tiny
URL, App Engine Pipelines is the--is where
the questions are. This is my blog if you
want to follow me. And thanks for you sitting
through that. Let's see, I can have to--thanks.
Let's see what happens here. I think there's
a mic here and a mic there. I don't have much
time. I'm going to be going--well, directly
after me, before you leave, there's a talk
from Mike Aizatsky who's also in the App Engine
team talking about the new Mapper API. I really
encourage you to stay for that. He's talking
about mapper and the [INDISTINCT] generation
and batch processing on App Engine. It's a
really good talk. I really encourage you to
check it out. And it has, you know, a lot
of kind of--it's not overlapping with my talk
at all, so it's very useful. So let me see
if there's any uploaded--will it be an extension
or removal of the 10-second limit of the request
to external websites? So it's a 30-second
limit now. Like I said, we're working on background
servers and addressable servers to--oh, I
gotcha, URL fetches. Yeah, I think Kevin said
yesterday during the file search that we're
trying our best to raise it into the 30-second
range and we understand that people want to
go up to multiple hours or indefinite or something
that we're aware of and we're working towards.
The memcaching can be a bottleneck. What are
the max throughputs? I've max out memcacher
like 120,000 requests per second. I have a
feeling that's not going to be the problem.
So, I mean, unless you're--I mean, that's
cool if you're doing that. That's great. That's
like a massive success. Cool. Let's take one
from public. Yeah?
>> Your ETA was it based upon an estimated
amount of work for the task or was it constant
because you know how App Engine performs?
>> SLATKIN: It depends. So, yeah, so the question
is the work--is the ETA on the batching based
on some constant idea or is it based on how
App--like the work I'm doing or was it based
on some characters of App Engine itself, the
characteristic of App Engine itself--so, both.
In the case of transactions, I know I shouldn't--to
be really safe, I shouldn't go more than one
transaction per second if I'm actually trying
to like write a lot of data at a time that's
why it's a good rule of thumb. For other stuff,
you know, if I'm doing URL fetches and I know
the average latency is five seconds, it doesn't
really help to batch more often than that
maybe. So it really depends on the problem
that you're dealing with. If you know you
have a lot of latency, then, it helps to batch
a lot, you know. For instance, if you're doing
a 20 URL fetch calls, you can do them all
the same time and then you can use one thread
to hold on for 20 seconds of latency here
or fit the 10 seconds latency. So, you can
eliminate your waiting cost by batching asynchronous
calls together, so, yeah. Yeah?
>> So, it looks to me that you're trying to
build a singleton pattern on top of Datastore
using materialized view and the other one
on the transient memory on memcache. You know,
in the case of Datastore, you--if you run
parallel tasks...
>> SLATKIN: Okay, yeah.
>> ...you run into--in an optimistic concurrency
control, you run into still data. In the case
of transient data, you lose the data if the
transient memory goes, you know, out of...
>> SLATKIN: Uh-huh. So what was your question?
>> So, is it easier to have something like
a transaction memory like a singleton pattern
instead of doing this?
>> SLATKIN: So, yes, that's--all right. Basically,
the question is, why go to the trouble like
this when you can just have global transactionality?
>> Like a singleton which is across distributed
system of course.
>> SLATKIN: All right, so if you want the
richness of the queries that we have, you
can achieve that. You cannot achieve global
ordering like we have in our Datastore and
also be singleton. It just doesn't work. Like
we have built something that, you know, it's
like the CAP theorem, right, you can't get
everything. And so, we've got a nice tradeoff
of these properties that let you scale extremely
wide and let you do rich queries with consistency,
but we have tradeoffs to come out of that
and one of them is we can't apply global orderings
like having a single database. But a lot of
people really want that which is part of why
we've announced that we're going to have SQL
servers that people can get that singleton
locking performance that they want, you know,
functionality that they want.
>> Addressable server is that going to solve
our problem of--transaction?
>> SLATKIN: It could. Why don't you come on
office hours? I think that's a really advanced
question, so we should talk about it then.
Yeah. Yes?
>> What's the limit on number of simultaneous
task queues running and is that something
we can control?
>> SLATKIN: So are you saying task per second
or threads?
>> Tasks that are running simultaneously.
>> SLATKIN: Yeah, it depends on their individual
throughput. I don't remember if the numbers
offhand. If you come to office hours, we should
have one for you, but I think the total is
50 tasks per second right now. Is that right?
Is it higher? Yeah, so.
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> SLATKIN: So--sorry, what?
>> SLATKIN: Oh, what about BigQuery, how does
it relate to this? That's a good question.
I don't know. I have to think about that.
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> SLATKIN: Yeah, big lines, yeah, exactly.
So, big--yeah, BigQuery, I guess, is offline
processing data mining. Yeah.
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> SLATKIN: No--yeah, it's not--BigQuery is--I'm
pretty sure you upload a huge amount of data
then delve into it. Yeah. So, I have time
for one last question.
>> So just curious on the real life example
on this. What's happening during the scheduled
outage when memcache is not available?
>> SLATKIN: Right, exactly. Well, when memcache
is not available, the Datasource is also not
available for rates. So in my case, with the
hub, I can't do anything anyway so I just
return 503s because memcache is down and then
I just--like on a hub that's what I do. So,
there's...
>> You don't schedule a whole bunch of tasks
that are accumulating during that time?
>> SLATKIN: So the task queue will do its
own back off so that if it knows that if the
Datastore is no longer can do rates, you can
determine that. The only thing that stops
during the kind of scheduled maintenance is
the--is writing new tasks and completing tasks.
But all the tasks that were already there
will complete after the scheduled maintenance
because they already have--work index is assigned
and the data items too and the tasks are there,
so if memcache disappears, they'll check for
the lock, the lock is not present, and then
they'll just go along their way.
>> Okay.
>> SLATKIN: So memcache--if memcache disappears
the tasks will still complete.
>> But during the outage there's no new tasks
that can be generated?
>> SLATKIN: That's correct, yes. That's--yes.
That's part of the tradeoff, yeah.
>> Thanks.
>> SLATKIN: All right, that's it. I'll be
outside to answer your question. But please
come to the next talk with Mike Aizatsky.
I really--it's a good one.